and what else another guy came up and I
was thinking about you know I've been
working in this 12-step stuff that I'm
doing they have you know you think about
you talk about family and people you
have resentments against and things that
are buried inside of you that can like
that can affect the way you behave daily
but you don't realize it you know it's
not like they're treasures but you don't
realize they're treasures at first
because resentments you know they can
really it's like a little edge inside of
you where it's supposed to be a curve
and so everything that goes around there
is choppy every time your thoughts or
your feelings pass through that canal of
that journey within if you're thinking
about something that even is related to
you know a previous experience you had
that you didn't like there or a person
that you don't like or a family member a
loved one or a parent or whatever you
have a resentment so then anytime
something else comes up that would kind
of use one of the same streets in your
brain or your feelings
instead of it being a curve it'll be a
you know a 90 degree angle and it's
choppy they're like speed bumps for the
way that you can love others to me
anyway you know I can't love people as
well if I have the speed bumps in me it
makes some kind of the highway of my
heart's got a lot of it's just a you
know it you're gonna have to have really
good insurance if you're gonna travel
down it because I got a lot of speed
bumps on it resentment anger things you
know previous experiences that are rough
that make my road rough and make it
rough for me to bring anybody down the
road and they had him young men that
came after the show and he said hey you
know I really appreciate some of the
stuff you talk about on the podcast when
you get into like just talking about
what you're feeling and stuff you know
my father my father was real old when I
was born you guys know that my dad was
born in 1910 and so I've been doing this
work recently just thinking about my my
dad and my relationship with him and
this young fella at the show said hey
you know my dad was born was 61 and and
that got me thinking even more about
just about my dad and just kind of how
you know I always had you know I'm like
I love my dad I'm grateful for him but
I've also always been a little bit angry
at him I didn't realize it I was always
angry because I didn't know him very
well you know I was 16 when he passed
away and he was 86 and uh you know I was
angry because I didn't know him because
he didn't know me you know a kind of a
and then I you know I realized that I
really kind of judged my father like I
didn't realize I always thought that is
one of the reasons we didn't know each
other very well was because because of
the age gap but I really started to
think back more on it and one of the
reasons also we didn't know each other
very well was because I really judged
him you know I really judged him for
being so old you know the kids would
make fun of him and then I kind of made
fun of him and I think sometimes I don't
even try to get to know him even though
I was young it wasn't my responsibility
really it was it was an ideal situation
but I didn't really try to get to know
him you know when I would have and I
would make the excuse well he shouldn't
had a kid when he was that old you know
what was he thinking well that's true
but if he doesn't have that I don't
exist so there's some validity there to
that argument but but uh but if I don't
if I don't exist but he gave me my
existence whatever however way it
happened you know he really gave me the
only important the most important gift
which is my experience of the world and
[Music]
judged him so much and kind of then I
didn't really get to know him you know
there were times I he probably thought
sometimes well maybe my son doesn't he's
not interested it or he he
I think maybe I was afraid to get to
know him because I knew he was gonna
pass away so it was probably like safer
to not get to know him you know
but I remember I chose to joke around I
would always make you know because other
people started making fun of my dad
because he was just so old man you know
and so I would make fun of him you know
sometimes because it's all I could do
it's the only thing I could do to kind
of survive was to also make fun of him
but but in doing that I didn't really
honor him I didn't really honor my
relationship with him that much I didn't
you know and I'm not really blaming
myself I'm not coming down hard on
myself
I just I'm trying to get to a place
where
where we're not think about fatherhood
and I think about parenting I'm trying
to you know pick these locks that keep
me from
[Music]
having a lot of emotions in those spaces
but I was really embarrassed to my
father you know I hate to say this man I
was embarrassed like uh you know when we
walked somewhere I walk kind of far
behind him or away from him you know
because he was so old I didn't and he
didn't notice that much because you know
when you get old and this one when I was
a kid when I was a kid I was real doting
on him I was real caring you know I
remember we would walk to church
sometimes and I would you know I make
sure that the leaves were off of a
sidewalk and I would make sure that
though that he knew that the I mean a
sidewalk in Louisiana dude good [ __ ]
luck bro that thing is a gangplank dudes
sidewalk in Louisiana that's a side work
they should call it that thing the first
thing is like that the next one is
straight up one of them is a damn
drawbridge because they got all the tree
roots popping through so you have one
piece of cement sidewalk the next piece
is a dam the third piece is off ramp
take you right over to uh Laplace where
Billy conforto lived r.i.p I mean the
sidewalk in Louisiana thing is dangerous
slip and fall dude slip and fall all the
way into the Lord's arms that thing's
killing senior citizens left and right
that's a side work baby there's no and
sorry ma'am ride and make sure that my
dad knew how the sidewalk was when we
were young so that we could walk
together you know
but then as he got older I remember like
we'd be somewhere and I would be you
know I'd walk away from him or you know
I remember like
I remember like he like you know I
remember like his skin sometimes on his
hands it was real old excuse me
I'm just cleared my throat and swallowed
my own mucus so I'm obviously a reptile
[Music]
but I remember his skin on his hands was
so old that sometimes you know when I
saw him who would make me like I loved
him and stuff but it would make me kind
of scared or it would make me
it make me kind of sad sometimes you
know when he touched me because
you know because he wasn't the way that
I wanted him to be you know and I'm and
I'm not
not said because this I don't think this
is like my fault or not you know I don't
want you to I'm not like in this kind of
woe is me space I just you know I want
to be able to
be as loving as I can and I know that
sometimes I have to examine
relationships in my life to see where I
have hang-ups
but yeah I was just embarrassed of him
you know the way he is because my dad my
dad was a handsome man you know he had a
uh he had a lovely girlfriend Miss
Maggie and she would make us some she
had that she lived in a nice place man
I'm her when I went to her place it was
like the nicest apartment we'd ever been
in big tall ceilings men you could have
a whole nother [ __ ] room in the
ceiling the ceiling was so high I said
damn just give me a hand like I'll go
live up there give me four hammocks you
know I'll just I'll just tarzan around
up there i'll build a little kitchenette
up there halfway up the wall give me
four hammocks I live in the corner of
the ceiling and she took care of
Davin he's real old you know she you
know she was probably six she would
probably 60 and my dad was you know at
that point he's 85 or something or she
were probably at 63 and she was fancy
she was like a high society woman you
know in New Orleans and that's still
very you know they got the fancy people
down there but she was a good woman you
know and she loved my dad and and they
were friends and yeah but I just
remembered seeing him like you know
walking around you know I remember I'd
sleep over there sometimes at her house
in the middle of the night and my dad
would get up to go to the restroom and
I'd see him in like the window and like
the moon like she had these big windows
that face right out on the Mississippi
River man she lived in a I don't even
know what it was it was over there and
uh across the river across the
Mississippi over there and um I uh I
can't remember it right now kind of by
Gretna but right off the right by the
river by the ferry anyway so and I would
see my dad walk like I see him walk and
he was just old you know and and I
didn't recognize it as much when he was
you know I'd see him fully clothed all
dressed up and he dressed up real nice
every day and then at night thought see
him in his body he seemed like a
dinosaur like an old dinosaur and I
think it made me scared you know it made
me as a kid it just but it made me angry
at him and I didn't realize this till
just I mean literally just this week and
and then I was thinking about it even
more on the flight home this morning
when this after this guy last night was
telling me he had a old father and by
hearing me talk about my dad sometimes
he could he could relate and that maybe
you're happy you know it made me feel
happy to know that you know we can
relate to each other uh but yeah made me
you know just made me look more my
relationship you know and I could add
more memories with him if I hadn't
judged my father so much you know he
wasn't like this or he you know he
couldn't do this he didn't have anything
uh
you know I just think I'm not mad at
myself I don't I want you to know that
I'm not like you know I just I
I could have been a better maybe could
have been a better son to him you know
and I know the circumstances weren't
ideal but but I just maybe could have
had him could have been a better son to
him sometimes you know I could have had
more pride you know I wish somebody had
taught me to have more pride in my
family when I was young because I didn't
know and then when other kids started
making fun of you know my situation in
the world like you know I joined them
and made fun of my situation as well
instead of having a sense of pride now
that's where you know my parents or the
world or the scenario or whatever that's
where that that's where you know my
father probably he could have done a
better job by helping me have a sense of
pride in our family and maybe he tried
and maybe and sometimes things just are
the way they are but but I never
realized that I was angry at my dad
until I wrote down this this resentment
thing it says I'm angry at my father and
then I have to write why I'm angry at
him so I have to really sit there and
think um and I was angry at him because
I didn't know him you never you know I
never got to know him you know and I
know he loved to sit and drink coffee
and speaking Spanish to his friends you
know I know he bought a Delta 88
off a black dude and had some speakers
in it they were [ __ ] ratchet and he
would just listen to talk radio with the
loudest bass you've ever heard coming
through the neighborhood I mean he never
heard a man roll through the
neighborhood with just the weather
report
60% 60% searcher churns oh cloud 40%
churns up hmm
I mean did it was [ __ ] crazy man and
he liked us you know good sleep in his
car at the park a lot of times and uh
but I was ashamed of them you know I was
ashamed of of
came to my father
and maybe it was a safety mechanism for
me too because I was afraid that if I
got to know him that I knew he was gonna
die just knew how time worked but I have
to look at this I have to look at that
relationship of my life because if
because it it affects the way today how
I look at time
it affects like how I look at age how I
look at you know wanting to have a
family and not one you know if I have
this built-up fear somewhere deep inside
of me that I'm not going to be able to
create a loving relationship with a
child
that comes from a scenario that's
irregular like an old very old man
having a son but if I let that faster in
me without examining it then it could
affect whenever if I decide to have a
son or not at all or have a child so I
have to look at those things but I was
embarrassed to my father you know um um
what else I wrote I had a list here of
things because I wrote this stuff to
hang on about my resentments
you know I'm and then I get upset
sometimes that I don't remember him and
I was going right in adolescence and
teen and you know getting erect and all
of that and I started doing masturbation
and whatever you know 13 12 bra his dick
City you could look at every state in
the universe as he look at any map when
you're a kid at 13 years old bruh and
his dick City population yeah boy but
yeah I mean I was ashamed of my father
[Music]
I miss him you know I realized that I
judged him and I realized by looking
through some of the things that I was
pretty judgmental and I don't know where
that judgment came from or how it
started I'm not ashamed him I'm not mad
at myself of it you know I'm not but I'm
glad that I'm able to see it a little
bit now that I was judgmental towards
people that loved me because
you know I was afraid to it cuz I was
afraid cuz I didn't know how to do that
you know I don't know how to love them
and by and by learning here's the thing
by learning what my sure my father had a
bunch of false he shouldn't had a kid at
that age or or he I'm glad he did though
it wouldn't what I mean he shouldn't
have I'm glad he did if he did and I
don't exist so but he maybe he should
have thought more about it maybe he did
you know I don't know maybe he thought I
know he thought he was gonna live to
like a hundred you know he always say
that so he'd always like to kind of
guarantee me that but
but I learned through this through doing
this process like why I'm angry at my
father I was ashamed to him I was
embarrassed to him I can't apologize to
him you know I can't love him he was
selfish
you know how I'm angry cause our
relationship wasn't what I wanted I
think that's one thing from the gate I
realized though our relationship this
isn't when I wanna have a father-son
relationship so I'm not gonna care about
it that much you know but
and then sometimes I felt a lot of times
like I used my dad because he was so old
that even if I did like regular kid kind
of mischief around him it always came
off like I always felt bad about it you
know cuz if you joke around with it you
you know you say you hide something from
your dad if he's thirty it's fine he'll
find that [ __ ] but you hide something
from your dad and he's 78 you hide his
car keys
dude he could look for a month so I
think I uh I developed this deep sense
of like feeling bad about myself because
I would do regular things that kid would
do but then I would see the effect that
they would have on an older person and
then I would feel so bad about it
because a kid's gonna do those things no
matter what but then when you see that
this old person can't deal with it and
then it makes you feel bad you know so I
think I developed this sense of like
shame a lot that kind of lives in me but
I don't realize it unless I start to
look at these relationships in my life
and so anyway that's something that I'm
learning to do like in my 12 steps you
know but but anyway let's get into some
calls man but I just want to say thank
you to the young man that shared what he
was thinking the other night on stage
and you know and then and then another
couple came up there and they got
engaged man oh man she was so happy you
know I saw this woman she teared up and
she was crying and you know the guy was
all he was so excited and man it's cool
you know I'm blah you know I'm blessed
man I am blessed to uh I'm blessed to be
able to feel I'm happy to be able to
even feel things I'm like you know it's
beautiful for me right now as I get to
still have a feeling about my father you
know and it's so funny as soon as I
started making this list the other day
and thinking about this stuff
immediately a lot more memories of my
father came in to me and in my brain in
a more comfortable space you know a lot
more things came into me where in the
memories I was more loving of him now
even immediately then I was like you
know the meetings were softer they had
the the memories were softer they had
more of a curve to him and this wasn't
such a just a little bit of lesson less
90-degree angles around my heart yeah
man I just yeah I got it just got me
thinking about the parental stuff and
family stuff and just you know uh and
just like
you
you know just just judgment and how much
judgment keeps me away from others I can
feel that sometimes even still today you
know I know I'm not doing good when I
start getting real judgmental because
judgment keeps me away from you it keeps
me away from someone oh look at them
look at that
oh look they're like that oh they have
that oh now sometimes it worked to
inspire me you know I judge the rich I
judge the greedy you know and some of
those and sometimes it works to inspire
me and that's felt like those things are
necessary but I'm gonna point in my life
now where I'm able to look and see okay
is this still serving me well or is this
just a thing that's keeping me away from
people you know and then it then it goes
down a well why why are you so afraid to
have somebody care about you why are you
so afraid to care about someone
this trick that's the devil out there
making you believe that or feel that a
Satan baby that's Lucifer brah
that's the Lucifer that darkness sniffer
and they think you the whole life you
think oh I'll just keep judging and
keeping people at a distance but guess
what there's this there's this there's
this thing in the distance making you
think oh you get that that you win
somehow that I or that I win somehow by
doing that I'm not saying you I'm saying
me but then I get to the end of my life
and I'll realize you know what I didn't
win anything by doing that that was a
that was a trick and the only thing I
won
was being alone or being less connected
to others you know and not only did I
miss out could could I could I miss out
on caring about people but I missed out
on feeling probably a lot of the love
that people have for me
you
because there's something right there
wrapped up neck their next-door
neighbor's their cheek-to-cheek their
conjoined twins when when I when I don't
when I can't love someone when I don't
want I judge and I keep someone away
from me
I keep me away from them I keep me away
from them and also what the [ __ ] I don't
know the [ __ ] I'm talking about let's
get into some questions man I but I
don't know man you know
yet I'm not being hard on myself because
know why I'm not saying what was me this
or that I'm not saying that I'm just
saying that I'm just saying I know that
there's I if I'm resentment about
something I'm angry about something I
need to go look at why I'm angry about
it and if I can eventually find a way
that I had some say in it some could
then at least it's now it's in my
control so instead of being angry at my
dad because he was so old and I didn't
get to a proper father-son relationship
instead I can take a little bitty piece
and say oh well you know what when I was
like 15 16 I could have probably been a
better son at some points then it puts a
little bit of it on me now it's now I
can have ownership of it and now I can
go apologize you know to my father's
grave if I want to and let him know and
not that I'm like because then it just
gives me ownership now I'm in control of
our relationship again and now I can
rebuild memories and and now I don't
have that now there's no anger between
us anymore you know now it's an
opportunity for us to for my brain and
heart to be like oh man good that
right-angle ain't there that right turn
that stop like those seven stop signs
you got built up at this intersection of
your emotions it's not there anymore and
it's just a beautiful curve man and you
can feel the love you can feel the love
man